looking at the world seriously and
rigorously you're saying that the
people who are running tech companies or
running
the mediums on which we can
exercise the idea of free speech are not
adults
i think not i think first of all a lot
of them are silicon valley
utopian businessmen where you talk a
utopian line and you use it
you've heard my my take which is that
the
idealism of every era is the cover story
of its greatest thefts
and i believe that in many ways the
idealism of silicon valley about
connecting the world a world of
abundance etc etc etc
is really about the software eating the
world as mark andreessen likes to say
through all these legacy properties and
by simply being
a bad tech version of
something that previously existed like a
newspaper you could immediately
start to dwarf that by aggregating
newspapers in their digital versions
because digital is so much more powerful
as a result yes we have lots of
manned children wandering around what
once was the bay area and is now austin
and miami and other places
um maybe singapore that um
all of these people that you know
these are friends of ours and they're
brilliant with respect to a certain
amount of stuff
but none of them can get off the drip
it's amazing that none of them have fu
money
we've got billionaires who don't have fu
money okay
i think the argument used by jack dorsey
was that there was an incitement of
violence
and not just that course by everybody
that was
banning people and then this word
violence was used
as a kind of uh just like extremism and
so on to
uh without much reason behind it you
think it's impossible for jack dorsey
anybody else
to be as you said an adult a grown-up
and
jack is pretty close to being the
groningen he seems like he is yeah he's
oh he's as he's under pressures as
you've discussed
he it seems that he's been on the verge
of
almost being quite serious and
transparent and real
i don't know where the jack dorsey that
i met went
and i worry that that must be
something behind the scenes that i can't
see from my perspective what i think
is the stress the burden of that
when people are screaming at you it's uh
zen monk he really is yeah jack is an
incredibly impressive person
intellectually
morally spiritually at least
for a couple of meetings i don't know
him very well but
i'm very impressed by the person i'm at
and i don't know where that person is
and that terrifies me but
do you think somebody could step up in
that way no
you so it does can does a human being
have the capacity
to be transparent about the reasoning
behind the banning
or do you think all banning eventually
uh all banning of people from mediums of
communication
is eventually destructive or it's
impossible for human beings to reason
with ourselves about it
you